yeah it's going to be Trump and Biden
again and the debate is going to be
Trump is going to go
Hunter body is horrible and another
thing he keeps taking pictures of his
penis disgusting and Joe is going to be
like he died in war
[Laughter]
M out of it I know and it's gonna be
awesome and I can't wait just because no
one else that we I mean I I mean
he's so old is there anyone else anyone
else I could see them Trump sneaking in
like who's gonna Harris
every time I bring this name up people
go I mean their reaction Gavin Newsom
Kevin Newsome you have a surplus yeah
Gavin Muslim is always like we have
Surplus here in California 200 billion
I'm like then [__] use it
[__] build housing for homeless
people [__]